VYACHESLAV EGOROV: My
name is Vyacheslav Egorov.
FLORIAN SCHNEIDER: My
name is Florian Schneider.
And we'll talk about
ahead-of-time compilation
in Dart.
VYACHESLAV EGOROV: Or rather,
Florian is going to talk,
and I will go and sit,
because we have just two talks
mixed into one-- so
not to make it awkward.
FLORIAN SCHNEIDER: Yeah.
Yeah, this is basically work
we've done since the last Dart
summit.
And yeah, that was
done by Slava, Ryan,
and me-- Ryan, who
couldn't be here today.
But I'll give you an overview of
what ahead-of-time compilation
looks like.
A little of background and
how this all started-- around
one and a half years
ago, we started
investigating if
it's feasible to run
Dart in an ahead-of-time
compiled setting.
And the reason back then
was that Flutter-- you
saw the demo in the
keynote, which is awesome.
We need to run some way
to run efficiently on iOS,
because we had a JIT
compiler, and that would only
work on Android.
And because of the
restrictions in iOS,
we can't really cheat there.
So initially, what
Flutter ended up doing is
they used the ARM
simulator on iOS.
That is working, but
super slow, so not
an option to actually
deploy an app.
So we started prototyping the
ahead-of-time compiler first
for Intel, to see if
it's possible, last year.
And then we ended up porting
it to ARM and ARM64, which
is needed for mobile, and
landed AOT support in the SDK.
And around last year in October,
Flutter started using it.
And what we did since
then is basically
improve it in terms
of speed and size.
We also found out
that, actually,
ahead-of-time compiled code
starts up a lot faster on iOS--
on Android as well.
So we actually added
support for Android.
And not directly related
to AOT compilation,
but in order to get a fast
development cycle also, in iOS,
we added an efficient
interpreter which is called DBC
for the iOS development cycle,
because you can't-- on Android,
you use the JIT compiler
during development.
And on iOS, you
need something that
is fast enough so you get
a smooth experience also
while developing.
So the way how we went about
this, we had the Dart VM.
And we had a JIT
compiler and implemented
a lot of optimizations there.
And the way we went about
it and got something
that was ready
for use in Flutter
in a short amount of time was
we used as many components
from the Dart VM that are shared
between the JIT and the AOT.
So the parser,
obviously, is the same.
It's the same language.
Many compile optimizations
like register location
is also basically re-used
between the two compilers.
The code generator, the
garbage collector, all these
are shared.
And we didn't have to
do that from scratch.
What we had to do is add
a bunch of new components
to that exclusively needed
for AOT compilation.
So we needed tree shaking
so that your compiled app is
small enough.
The download size should
be reasonably small.
We added some
AOT-specific compiler
parsers to speed up the code.
For startup, we implemented new
snapshot reading and writing.
Basically, the data stored
in your compiled app
in your binary should be
initialized as fast as possible
at startup.
Another small detail
that's maybe not obvious,
regular expressions
[INAUDIBLE] before.
So we had to add an interpreted
version for regular expressions
to be able to run on iOS.
So I'll talk about the
three main challenges
that we faced in this effort.
The first one is basically
just to make it work.
Because originally,
Dart VM was not
meant to run in an
ahead-of-time compiled world.
And so in order to make
the compiled code suitable,
we needed to make it generate
relocatable code and also
isolate-independent code.
I will talk about what that
means in detail just in a bit.
And sine we wanted
to share, also,
many components between
the two compilers,
we ended up changing,
for example,
a calling convention
that was needed,
a new calling
convention, in both.
And so we can pass
[INAUDIBLE] the current thread
object in a register.
And we ended up changing
that both for JIT and AOT.
So that means we could
run the code in AOT,
and the JIT code only got
a tiny bit bigger, I guess,
on the order of a few percent.
So here's a quick overview
of the Dart VM, the heap
organization in the JIT world.
You have your one, or
two, or many isolates,
and they have their own
data part of the heap.
They have their own
code part of the heap.
And almost nothing is shared.
We share a bunch
of read-only data,
but all the isolates have
their own code specific
for each isolate.
So in AOT world, the
data part of the heap
is as it was before.
But what changes is that
the code part is now
shared between all isolates.
Because the code now
is compiled to binary
and comes from a
binary, so there's
only one version which needs
to be used by all isolates.
And the data is
shared as before.
So the code part also
becomes a little bigger,
because it has to
contain the code that's
used by all isolates.
And basically, that's the code
left over after tree shaking.
So challenge number
two basically
was optimizing the
code, making it fast.
And here the problem is that
the type feedback is missing.
So in the JIT compiler, we
used dynamic type feedback.
And the compiler has to
figure out the types by itself
in ahead-of-time compilation.
That means less specialized
code, more dynamic dispatches.
But on the other hand,
we can rely on a closed
world for AOT compilation.
And this is done by basically
restricting the language
in certain ways.
So for example, there's
no real deferred loading.
You can use deferred
loading, but it
will happen when you build
the app at compile time.
There's also no
spawnUri from isolate.
That's so you can't spawn
an isolate with new code.
So all the code is needed
at the compile time.
And the third thing is there's
no mirrors supported in the AOT
world.
And this is mainly needed
for code size reasons.
And the other part
of making it fast
is making the startup
really snappy and fast.
So these two, basically, peak
performance and startup, those
are the two things
that we had to address.
So here's a performance
comparison of AOT versus JIT.
I'll talk about peak
performance and startup time.
Since we started using the
ahead-of-time compiler,
we improved a lot since
the first version,
on some benchmarks,
even much more than 2x,
but around that
order of magnitude.
We basically made
many optimizations
shared between
the two compilers,
and we added a bunch
of new optimizations
like tracking type of fields
or identifying unique methods
and speeding up the
method dispatch for those.
And for startup, basically, as
soon as we started using AOT,
we got a huge boost.
And that's mainly
because there's
no warmup cost involved.
You get stable performance
right from the start.
The code and the read-only data,
they are mapped into memory
from the binary.
So there's no code
generation needed
that would slow down
startup in the JIT world.
And in addition to that, we
added the new faster snapshot
format within load deprecation.
And that helps both the
JIT and AOT bit out,
so it gave another factor
of 2 in terms of startup.
So here I'll just show
a few sample benchmarks
that we were tracking
over the last year.
And this just to show
you-- these are benchmarks.
Some of them are taken
from the Fultter repo,
so they have a bunch
of micro-benchmarks.
The blue line is
the AOT performance.
The red line is the
JIT performance.
And you can see, on
some benchmarks, we--
so AOT performance improved
on all of them over time.
On some of them, we are closing
in to reach JIT performance.
On others, we actually exceed
JIT performance already,
which may be a little
bit surprising,
but it's perfectly reasonable.
So for example, the one in the
lower right corner, dart2js,
which is basically an
ahead-of-time compiled
version of dart2js compiling
a simple HTML application--
and here it turns out the input
is not large enough, actually,
for JIT to catch up in
terms of performance.
So it may be running
for five to 10 seconds.
So for this, the
ahead-of-time compiled code
is actually almost
twice as fast.
Also, the animation benchmark is
much more smooth with the AOT,
because there are no
parsers happening.
So we are not always
faster than the JIT.
There's benchmarks.
For example, on
DeltaBlue, we are only
at 20% of JIT performance.
On Flutter
micro-benchmarks, you saw,
we are between 65% and 115%.
So there, we are pretty much
on par with the JIT, on dart2sj
as well, between 75% and
180% of JIT performance.
But there's still
more to be done
for some of the work loads.
In terms of startup,
we got, immediately,
around a 3x faster startup
of the Flutter gallery,
probably even more.
I measured this some time ago.
I guess, in the
last month or so,
there have been
more improvements.
So that number is, I
would say, conservative.
And also, dart2js is-- if
you compile a small program,
it's a lot faster.
And only if you
compile, for example,
dart2js with dart2js itself,
which is a really big program,
the JIT will eventually catch
up and exceed AOT performance.
I want to take a short minute
to talk about the experiment
that we just recently started.
Basically, we
thought about, what
about combining the two benefits
of the two worlds, JIT and AOT.
So just in the
new start version,
which is not in the state
channel yet, but version 1.21,
we added a new hybrid
snapshot format.
And we could imagine--
which is basically
having shared code for fast
startup plus the JIT compiler
to optimize further
once you are running.
And we experimented using that
for our own tools basically.
dartanalyzer,
dart2js should also
start up fast if you use
them from the command line.
And who knows, maybe once
phones are powerful enough,
you could also imagine
using something
like that on the phone.
The third challenge is
making the compiled output
small enough.
And here, as I said,
we have tree shaking.
So basically, all the code
that's imported by your app
but not used will
be dropped when
you create the binary snapshot.
And this is done automatically.
We also limit when we--
before we write out
the compiled code and
data into the snapshot,
we eliminate all unused
or duplicate data, VM
internal data, classes,
libraries, functions, types.
What we do, also, to
make the code smaller,
we do less aggressive
inlining than in the JIT.
That's part of the trade-off
between code size and speed.
And we have to find a balance to
make download sizes reasonable.
And the fourth part here
is that, basically, we
could remove all the
compiler-related code
from the runtime.
So we have a stripped down
version of the Dart VM runtime
that basically just contains
the necessary bits and pieces
to run AOT code.
Yeah, so that concludes part
one of the presentation.
I showed you that,
basically, Dart
is ready for AOT compilation.
And the best way to
try out this technology
is to create your Flutter
app or download the gallery
and try it out there.
Or you can experiment with
the Dart SDK directly,
but I think the Flutter tool is
a really nice way to experiment
with AOT code.
And we're working
in many directions
to make it even better.
And I'll hand it
over to my colleague
Slava, who will talk
about one of the things
that we are doing to
make it even better.
VYACHESLAV EGOROV: Yes.
Thank you, Florian.
[APPLAUSE]
In case you were wondering
why I was there on stage
to begin with, I'm back.
And I'm going to talk
about something completely
different from what
Florian told you before.
And it's different in the sense
that it's highly experimental.
Stuff that Florian
told you about
can actually be
used in production.
Like, you can compile a
Flutter app ahead of time
and deploy it into the
Play Store, so it's good.
And the stuff now is probably
completely unuseful for you.
But we need to occupy
the time a little bit,
so Bob put me on stage.
If we take a step
back and look at how
the Dart ecosystem
of tools looks like,
we will discover
that a lot of tools
these days are actually
ahead-of-time compilers.
Because the platforms
you are running Dart on,
like browser or
iPhone, they require
you to compile Dart
code ahead of time
into either JavaScript
or machine code.
And on this picture,
you can also
put the analyzer which compiles
the Dart code ahead of time
to errors and stuff like
that, and shows it to you.
But to not make this confusing,
I will remove the analyzer.
And if we zoom in on
those tools that we have,
we discover that, inside, they
contain a lot of orange boxes.
And what I'm trying to
show with this picture
is that they contain
some components inside.
And if we start looking
at those components,
we discover that they're very
similar in the beginning.
So when your Dart source
arrives into this tool,
it needs to be parsed.
It needs to be understood.
The libraries need to be
loaded from somewhere.
It needs to understand what
object is, what string is,
and so on.
But as you approach
the end of the tool
from the side from which
the code comes out,
like JavaScript code
and machine code,
you discover that they
are very different.
And of course, the
question arises,
why do we even have the
similar components duplicated
between these tools.
And they're really duplicated.
Like for example, dart2js has
its own parser for Dart code.
DDC, Dart Development Compiler,
is using the analyzer parser
to parse the Dart code.
And the VM has its
own C++ parser.
Like, it's written with C++.
And it doesn't make much sense
to duplicate these components.
So what we are trying
to do, and what
I am going to
introduce now, to you,
is this project called Kernel.
The name was selected
purely through a competition
of the most confusing words
to choose for this project.
We thought about calling it
"Core" and stuff like that,
but "Core" is even more
confusing than "Kernel."
So this is a simplified
representation
of the Dart language.
It's like an AST format.
It's not the bytecode, but
it's a simplified Dart AST.
It has a binary form as well.
And it's designed to make
a transformation friendly.
So we have a set
of tools to compile
to Kernel from Dart
source and a set of tools
to write it in the binary form.
You can load it back, transform
it, and save it again.
So where does it
fit on this picture?
Well, ideally, we would like to
arrive to something like that.
You start with a
Dart source, and you
compile it to Kernel
using this dartk compiler.
Then, you have a set of tools
that can analyze and transform
this representation.
And then you pass it
over to back end, which
knows how to do its job,
like compile it to JavaScript
or compile it to
the machine code.
And that's basically it.
So obviously, this is the
future, a possible future,
if we discover that this
gives considerable benefits.
And today, what
we have is that we
have the compiler
and transformation
parsers implemented.
We are experimenting
with different analyzers,
which I will show you
a little bit later.
And we modified VM
in such a way that it
can load both source and the
Kernel as well, on the side.
So you can compile your
application to Kernel
and then load it
into VM and rejoice.
So what are the benefits
of having these components
moved out and shared?
Well, if we start looking
at the language features
that Dart has, we
discover that Dart is not
a very simple language anymore.
It's simpler than
some languages,
but it still has a lot
of different features
which make it very expressive.
And these features come at an
implementation cost, right?
If you look at the history
of async/await for example,
it had to be implemented across
multiple different tools,
and it took a long time.
So our approach to
this is different.
We suggest that you can do the
sugaring on the kernel level.
So essentially, the
kernel that comes in
is the kernel with
async/await features,
but the kernel that comes
out is the one where
these features are stripped.
And here's an example
of what we do.
We convert-- this is the
kernel after the desugaring.
And in reality, you
can desugar all the
await-- I think,
await-- features
to a single yield feature.
And then your back ends only
need to support the yield.
And I don't recommend
you reading this code,
so I even reformatted
it a little bit
to make it slightly unreadable.
Another feature that is kind
of simple on the surface
is the closures.
But in reality, people that
encounter closures, especially
those people who
programmed Java before,
they ask, why do we
even need closures.
Closures can be just
represented as classes.
And really, that's a very
interesting question.
Why do we need closures?
So we are trying to
remove closures away
through the kernel
transformation.
We have a transformer-- you can
check it out, how it's written.
There is a link
to GitHub-- which
converts all closures in the
program into their classes.
And you can see there
is a context which
will contain the captured
variables and so on.
So it's just a very
simple transformation.
Another thing is types.
Dart has types.
What if everything that
you can do with type
could be written
just as a Dart code?
Have you have asked
this question?
Like, with is check,
can it be just written
as some simple Dart code?
Well, it turns out it can be.
And we have a transformer
that just attaches
the field that will contain
the type of an object
into the class.
And then it converts
all the is checks
to some simple Dart expressions
which call some helper methods.
And all of this is written
just in Kernel and Dart.
So these are the sort
of transformations
that can be shared between
the different back ends,
thus simplifying the back
ends and allowing you
to evolve the language faster.
Because now you don't need to
be a specialist in both C++
and Dart to go and implement
a new language feature.
You can just go and
implement it once
as a kernel-to-kernel
transformation in Dart.
So that's our goal, to make
the language evolution faster
and simpler.
And it'll allow you to port Dart
to new platforms also easier.
And we are not only looking
into the transformations.
We also look into the
ways to analyze the code.
Lake for example, both
dart2js and Dart VM,
they need to perform a
global type inference
to generate high-quality code
in the ahead-of-time setting.
Without knowing what
a variable points to,
you can't really do a
fast call, for example,
to a certain method.
So we have a prototype of
a global type inference
over the kernel representation.
And here is the output
that it produces.
So you can see
that the variables
on the left-hand side,
they don't contain any type
annotations.
But after the global
type inference,
we know that field f will
contain precisely an instance
of x, and that can be null.
And for example, the parameter
y, to the constructor,
will be precisely an instance
of y, but it cannot be null.
And if you listened to the
talk about strong mode,
you know that strong mode gives
you some of these benefits.
But for example,
it doesn't contain
any nullability information.
So these things, they
can complement each other
very well.
Like, strong mode can
give you better things
to seed your analysis with,
but this kind of inference
provides the data that
strong mode does not.
So yeah, that's
basically end-of-file
for this presentation.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]